thank you all building our new kingdom
won't be easy
but we will build it a beautiful
bountiful Kingdom where everyone can
live happily ever after
I want you all to join me on this
journey the road ahead may be a long one
but at the end of it there is hope
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ninokuni two revenant kingdom is
ambitious
it's a character-driven RPG that doubles
as a kingdom simulator and even
occasionally becomes a realtime strategy
though these components don't always
feel like parts of the same whole
ninokuni - compels you to care and put
your best foot forward
it's the whimsical setting it's the
demanding combat it's the tangible
feeling of growth that comes from being
a well-rounded ruler there's something
worthwhile around every corner and
usually something pretty to admire along
the way
[Music]
you can concisely summarize ninokuni -
as the wholesome story of Evan a boy
Prince asked to buy traders on the day
of his coronation who wishes to unite
warring nations under a banner of peace
armed with steadfast ideals he
repeatedly dismantled sinister
adversaries because they too are
actually good at heart they've merely
been corrupted by powerful dark forces
it's familiar fantasy fair and a bit
safe at times but ninokuni - bears no
shortage of interesting moments for
example Evans adult consul Roland is a
dimension tripping president from the
modern-day cast into a strange time and
place in the aftermath of a catastrophic
military assault while this intriguing
origin story is rarely referenced after
the fact the kingdoms he and Evan visit
offer up interesting qualities of their
own there's gold paw a society that
worships Lady Luck her divine power is
channeled through a giant multi-armed
statue that rolls a six-sided die to
decide everything from criminal
prosecution to raising or lowering taxes
you'll also have to navigate a kingdom
monitored by an enormous all-seeing eye
where love in all forms is considered a
criminal offense I will never understand
why the people love you solely under
weak insipid men but love you they do
without you I would be nothing that is
what they whisper is it not you no Kuni
to dedicates a lot of time to exploring
his unusual societies elevating the
otherwise standard RPG tale to something
far more interesting than you'd
initially expect to do this however the
game is forced to concede that
occasionally even a king as peaceful as
Evan will have to bear arms considering
his impassioned pleas for a world
without war the game's simple inter
infrequent RTS skirmishes
rock-paper-scissors battles that require
resource management feel notably
contradictory but standard battles are
so flashy and exciting that you'll never
think twice about the peace-loving King
being in constant battle
[Music]
you know Kuni two's combat takes place
entirely in real-time
apart from pausing to consume items and
despite the game's childish airs fights
are surprisingly demanding your party
consists of three allies and for Hegel
T's collectible miniature Goofy
familiars that randomly offer buffs and
attacks during battle you can only
control a single person at a time but
that alone gives you three melee weapons
to manage a ranged weapon magic skills
to consider and interlinked meters to
monitor on top of defensive concerns you
need to be aware of your surroundings at
all times in order to block or dodge
incoming attacks a far cry from the
first eno-kun ease turn-based battles
needless to say it can take a few hours
to grow comfortable managing all these
systems at once but you're rarely put at
a disadvantage your ai-controlled allies
are good at self-preservation and
dishing out damage and your higgledy
friends regularly offer up bursts of
healing magic or powerful attack to keep
things moving
while you can use gear to influence an
individual character strengths and
weaknesses you also earn a secondary
type of experience that gets funneled
into the tactics tweeker a tool that
lets you adjust team wide attributes and
how the game rewards your efforts you
have plenty of opportunities to take on
quests under level and being able to
slightly dial up your effectiveness
against a particular element or enemy
type it's a valuable means of punching
above your weight when pushing yourself
against an enemy 10 to 20 levels higher
than you eking out a victory through
clever preparation and a masterful
performance you can feel downright
incredible given that you can find ways
to overcome seemingly impossible odds
you can actually get by without grinding
at all to that end the game is also
designed to keep you from dulling your
enthusiasm in unnecessary battles as
low-level enemies simply ignore you
unless you run into them first knowing
you could bypass trivial fights makes
the prospect of exploring the world more
enticing as the story carries on and
ensures that you're only focused on
things with worthy of your attention
[Music]
it's easy to imagine how ninokuni two
could get by and its quirky characters
engaging story and real-time combat
alone but evan isn't just trying to
unite other nations he's building a new
kingdom of his own from a humble castle
nestled between mountains and shore your
lot of land will grow to contain dozens
of buildings and facilities while not
the most complex management sim out
there anyone who wants to push the
limits of their kingdom can easily pour
a dozen hours into forging new
developments and reaping greater
financial and practical rewards
everything in your kingdom takes money
to fund and time to develop but more
than just investing in these services
you need to staff them with citizens
from across the world this means
tackling a lot of side quests acquired
either by mingling with the populace or
by completing tasks for the task master
by a large side quests are either a
fetch quest or a kill X number of enemy
bounty these are common fare for RPGs
but nevertheless frustrating to see
relied upon so heavily here on the other
hand you no Kuni choose humorous writing
and endearing NPCs shine through lending
something worthwhile to even the most
common interactions in fact many of the
people you meet in passing are far more
interesting than the four human
characters that ultimately join Evan and
Roland on the ground we have known as
here you need the proper accreditation
before I let you touch my book ewokese
ya for whatever reason very little time
is spent developing their stories after
the enter the fold but even if they
offer little more than one liners during
most important events they are at least
invaluable allies in battle that
introduce a healthy selection of skills
then there is lofty
who while not a deep character is the
game's comic relief and an endless
source of amusement with yellow skin a
pointy head and a red torso he's what
you might imagine Lisa Simpson looks
like if someone described her but forgot
to mention she's human in almost every
scene be it serious or n't consequential
lofty often lingers just off-center with
a dim-witted stare and when he speaks he
cuts through scenes with wry wit and
even regularly calls out the team for
repeatedly tanking on errands and doing
strangers favors he's a massive benefit
to the overall experience
even within battle he primarily wanders
aimlessly during a fight but on rare
occasions offers a ball of light that
causes a character to enter a temporary
state where magic can be used freely
ninokuni - really wouldn't feel the same
without loft action despite the fact
that famed Japanese animation house
Studio Ghibli isn't involved this time
around veteran artists from the studio
have injected the sights and sounds of
ninokuni - with distinctly recognizable
whimsy of which lofty is but one example
you see it in the characters and
environments at large and you hear it in
the soundtrack composed by Joe Hisaishi
a veteran of numerous Ghibli films in
the original ninokuni soundtrack the
feeling is often upheld by a clean and
colorful cartoon aesthetic but there are
also plenty of times when you no Kuni -
shifts into a different and far less
appealing style when exploring the world
map managing your kingdom and diving
into RTS skirmishes the camera pulls
back and everything is given a
rough-hewn super-deformed appearance
that you can bend over backwards and
call it a potentially necessary evil
that doesn't excuse the sinking feeling
that there must have been a better way
one that doesn't require the game to
hide its lovely cel shaded face near the
end of your journey
this shift rears its head during a
battle that's intended to feel epic and
intimidating but instead falls flat due
to the simple presentation and
impersonal perspective one last reminder
that ninokuni - despite its outstanding
qualities bear some obvious flaws
[Music]
ninokuni - is a robust game that offers
ample ways to spend your time and even
if they are all to the same level of
quality it's easy to appreciate how they
collectively contribute to the bigger
picture it's chock-full of exciting
battles and surprising story moments
that make for a far more memorable
experience and you initially expect
leaving you impressed by your own
accomplishments if you didn't play the
first game don't let this one pass you
by to NATO nations be joined for the
sake of the world let the banners of war
and air again be unfurled united we
stand as one single land
[Music]
[Music]